ce qui me critiquent en est pour quelque
chose c'est avec rooney mais avant de
partir avec nous dans ce but nous a mis
au point un tel montant un gros
spectacle pour une tournée mondiale
est-ce pas là ses parents
pour laval a changé mais c'est justement
un terrain voilà je vous faudrait qu'à
pense sérieusement son habit attend le
bon moment pour leur dire que je veux
lancer une version il faut entendre par
un départ j'avais mes films danseuse
mamie bonne biologie amazigh ton
partenaire est blessé qui termine dans
quelques jours je pressens qu'il fait
avec tapas quand moi je veux la
combattre
moi non mais c'est un bon danseur on
sait ce que ça veut dire leur pote
deuxième chance on fait à ma façon
comment je fais pas tu le connais de
haut
j'accepterai jamais sans succès
la danseuse avec le plus de potentiel
que j'ai connue depuis des années mais
j'ai pu me contenir
c'est encore ma chance mais capable de
jouer tous les deux
m